lansana kouyaté l'ancien premier
ministre de la guinée bonsoir à vous
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france vous pensez que alpha condé il
dit prendre atteint 2 de cette
convention du parti qu'il appelle donc à
se présenter pour un troisième mandat
vous pensez qu'il va aller jusqu'au bout
nous sommes aux vagues
je prends à plat ne veut pas bill
quelque chose venant de lui ça veut dire
simplement qu'il entrait encore de jouer
sur le temps à mon avis il y a pour cela
deux raisons d'abord il a dit que ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est à dire les membres
de son parti qui l'a appelée elle
persiste au lieu des pigistes et qu' il
faut qu'il soit 530
il faut qu'ils comprennent que ceux ci
sont d'accord pas s'ils ne sont pas ces
dix ans de mensonges dix ans de
promesses qui leur ont été tenues qui
naquit n'ont pas été respectées à
quelques mois de son départ
et comme à chaque fois près d'une
échéance
ils lancent un projet il promet de
gauche à droite et sans que cela n'ait
aucune chance d'être réalisé ils
oublient à la minute où il est élu ces
gens le savent
ce qui porte à ce jour d'hui au sein du
rpg le disent ils disent on a marre des
promesses non tenues par andrew bras il
le site même alors si c'est s'ils
étaient sûrs aujourd'hui qu'ils avaient
harmonie et soutien de sa base ceux qui
l'ont créé et contre lesquels elle a
déployé d'autres forces nouvelles à qui
donne tout au détriment de ceux qui
l'ont mis là je suis certain que s'il
était sûr que tout cela allait bien se
passer
il n'allait pas tenir le langage qu'il a
tenus il ya une réforme de la
constitution
adopté en début d'année qui permet de
l'état de briguer un troisième mandat
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans
nos beaux pays africains on voit aussi
que l'action se pose en côte d'ivoire
aujourd'hui avec le troisième mandat
potentiel du président alassane ouattara
même scénario même si c'est pas le même
contexte en guinée qu'est ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui avec la classe
politique africaine aux avez raison de
dire que c'est pas le même contexte le
contexte guinéen est le plus gravissime
parce que il a attendu la constitution
dont vous parlez a été soumise au peuple
au forceps au mois de mars le 22 mars
c'est au moins d'octobre que le la de
l'élection est convoquée par le
président l'élection présidentielle et
vous voyez le temps ça fait six mois
sept mois il atteint la dernière minute
pour changer à sa guise parce que il est
le maître absolu
cela ne se fait pas à quoi d'ivoire pour
la côte d'ivoire c'est différent de sa
deuxième fait cette constitution dont il
a proclamé un résultat hors de tous les
sens
91 % qui ont dit qu'ils auraient dit oui
alors qu'il ya eu des mots et a eu une
fosse commune en zérékoré dans la forêt
du 1er mai c'est connu de tous et avec
tous ces dégâts
il promulgue la pression qu'il dit avoir
été votée par le peuple dans cette
publication il ya quinze modifications
vous pensez que vous le connaissez très
bien alpha condé puisque vous l'avez
soutenu lors de sa première élection
c'était en 2010 vous étiez son allié
et vous l'avez vous avez créé votre
propre parti vous avez rejoint
l'opposition
en 2011 parce qu'il nous dit qu'il n'a
pas tenu ses promesses
est-ce que vous pensez que s'il va au
bout il risque de plonger le pays dans
la violence
absolument et je vous corrige d'abord en
disant que mon parti est écrié avant que
je my le soutenir au 2e tour mois
jusqu'à candidats déjà au premier truc
contre lui et tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui de travel jalabert j'étais
probablement le seul qui avait dénoncé
tout ça lors du premier tour j'ai dit
qu'il ne pouvait pas parce que il ne
connaissait pas parce que il avait des
méthodes
je vous assure
après les 100 premiers jours j'ai dit
que son bilan était déjà globalement
négatif au moins du point de vue des
tendances à ce ce qui le montraient déjà
c'était la division de la guinée c'était
la pauvreté et la misère et c'était
l'absence d'état
c'était la mauvaise gouvernance à nos
maux donc moi ça m'étonne pas et tous
les guinéens et l'opposition comment
elle va s'organiser face à une
éventuelle candidature du président
alpha condé il ya aussi un opposant qui
s'appelle cellou dalein diallo qui est
issu de la communauté peule et c'est ce
qu'on dit aux textes un obstacle
d'ailleurs d'appartenir à la communauté
paul pour pouvoir accéder au pouvoir en
guinée
c'est ce que c'est lui qui a réuni tout
le crois pas on est dans une alliance
qui à faible qui s'appelle déjà fin de
ces front national pour la défense de la
constitution
il s'agit pas d'une ethnie il s'agit pas
d'un groupe régional
il s'agit de l'avenir du peuple de
guinée du présent et de l'avenir du
peuple guider ce peuple guinée vit mal
sur une nourriture question d'école
questions de santé
tout ce qui doit être fondamentalement
régler pour que le peuple soir dans un
bonheur relatif n'est pas fait célèbre
pilleurs qui pis c'est les voleurs
qu'ils voient et pendant ce temps que le
peuple ait laissé abandonné à son sort
par l'électricité
pado je vous assure sur 150 km on a créé
à qui diable 150 kilomètres la route
est-il détériorait que vous faites 7
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui quitterait
paris pour aller qui sans marquerait à
paris par vol d'oiseau pour aller à
conakry risque d'arriver à conakry avant
celui qui doit faire 150 km en véhicule
ne soit arrivé à destination
vous vous imaginez et toute la guinée
comme ça l'une des émissions phares ici
pour les routes les infrastructures
routières je crois que c'est la 5 ou a
faim il ya une chaîne en tout cas comme
ça les routes
impossible de l'histoire la guinée a été
l'un des premiers clients parce qu'ils
ont montré et c'est ce qui est dommage
ça me fait mal
en tant qu'unité l'élection pas la peine
de trouver la différence des ethnies
c'est le président est en train
d'exacerber touche l'élection elle est
prévue pour le 18 octobre 2020 elle aura
lieu cette élection vous pensez dans le
cadre
d'un troisième mandat du président alpha
condé il c'est une élection propre elle
peut pas avoir lieu vous le savez très
bien
il ya eu 2 millions 400 mille faux
électeurs qui était inclus dans le
fichier électoral après la réaction de
la francophonie et qui a eu le courage
de dire que vraiment elle ne peut pas
observer une telle élection ou untel une
call for death tout aux yeux
donc elle s'est retirée et après ils ont
dit que bon il va enlever les 2400 les
deux millions quatre cent maintenant
vous savez ces revenus encore par voie
de l'ordinateur dans le land anglais
dans les ordinateurs de la ceni c'est là
bas lansana kouyaté je le disais vous
connaissez bien elle faconde et il n'a
pas encore donné sa réponse à votre avis
quelle sera cette réponse il va aller
candidater pour un troisième mandat
certains qu'il va aller au prix de tout
ce qui aura comme manifestation au prix
de tout ce qu'il y aura comme répression
de cette manifestation
c'est tout ce qu'il fait là ce sont des
artifices pour que pacy quoi son
électorat ses propres militants et les
crânes naïf et se lie quand je vais à
dire non non il faut d'abord que
j'écoute ceux qui m'ont amené là ça va
flatter leur ego et ils vont penser que
cette fois ci tiendra sa promesse il ne
tient aucune promesse
c'est une promesse aujourd'hui et le
lendemain c'est l'oubli total
sinon même le mépris et pour conclure
rapidement comment vous expliquer le
silence jusqu'à présent dans des
organisations africaines l'union
africaine par exemple et la cédéao la
communauté économique des états
d'afrique de l'ouest et ils se sont
d'abord éteindre le feu de calme et ça
c'est tout organiser
soit ils sont dans leur rôle ne pas en
disant non aller au dialogue acceptera
sa certains c'est ce que les
anglo-saxons appellent le libre service
et ils le font ils le disent mais
fondamentalement qu'est ce qu'ils
peuvent déployer des troupes
c'est impossible la guinée n'est pas la
gambie et il n'y a pas de démarcation
claire et nette et le mode opératoire
la stratégie opératoire d'entrée et de
sortie sont définis en même temps quand
on doit faire intervenir pour séparer
les uns et les autres
celui qui parle devant vous russell
alpha condé il est déjà parent
signalements à la cour pénale
internationale
il a été signalé et au jour il ya une
semaine
condamné saisi deux fois le tribunal
français a été saisie de deux fois pour
détournement de fonds puis la nation
guinéenne pour la moelle et vous merci
les gars merci lansana kouyaté pourra
avoir réagi en direct sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes l'ancien premier
ministre de la guinée merci